hi I'm Erik Bosse and Star Wars the last
Jedi has been obsessed over every which
way on this channel but there is yet
another deeper layer of meaning to this
film that is in many ways even more
fascinating than the nerdy Star Wars
Easter eggs and nothing against Star
Wars trivia it's what gives me like
meaning but we got to talk about the
music in sound design by now you've
probably noticed how John Williams tends
to echo his past iconic scores at key
moments in the new movies
but it turns out in the last Jedi he
reached a whole new level of symphonic
complexity I'm gonna point out seven
specific moments that I noticed in the
last Jedi with hidden meaning in the
audio and obligatory spoiler warning for
the last gen now recently the New Yorker
pointed to a catalog of Star Wars music
collected by film music scholar Frank
layman it's essentially a list of Star
Wars light motifs without going too deep
into music theory a light motif is a
smaller fragment of a musical theme that
represents a specific idea or feeling in
a dramatic narrative is developed by the
German composer Richard Wagner who used
them in his operas to trigger characters
looking inwardly on their characters
motivations and then to come up over and
over again throughout the piece often a
well-placed light motif alone can do all
the talking for a character let's
actually look at this early example in
the last Jedi
when Supreme Leader Snoke scolds kylo
Ren for his childish impersonation of
his grandfather Darth Vader pay
attention to how the moment Snoke says a
new Vader Williams adds this not too
subtle light motif of the Imperial March
the music of Darth Vader in the Empire
[Music]
interestingly this is the last time
Williams uses the Imperial March theme
this overtly in the score for the last
Jedi instead immediately after the scene
ends kylo smashes his Vader style helmet
in the elevator and Williams scores it
with his kylo Ren theme from the force
awakens
[Music]
this replacement of the old with the new
and the letting go of the past is all a
key theme for the last Jedi and Williams
uses this musical ship to underscore it
let's move on to the next interesting
audio choice when Ray is following look
around in the island you may have
noticed some mysterious whispers calling
her back to the Jedi tree library movies
sound designers Matthew wood and Rand
Kleiss confirmed that the whispers were
hearing here are pieces of the Jedi Code
there is no emotion there is peace there
is no ignorance there is knowledge there
is no passion there is serenity there's
no chaos there is harmony there is no
death there is the force I swear I read
that off the prompter I didn't have that
memorized I'm I don't wanna dialogue
lucasfilm's story group added this chant
to the jedi mythology in the 2015 novel
dark disciple wood and Kleist brought in
a group of voice actors to whisper these
words and then the editors twisted the
audio around to mask and echo it their
idea was that the books and the tree
would be calling out to Rey with these
voices whispering the Jedi code for our
next sound moment there's another john
williams light motif when kylo targets
his mother leia on the bridge of the
Radice
[Music]
the music here is Laius theme from the
original trilogy
in this moment this mother and son can
sense each other's presences via the
force so no dialogue is necessary
Williams uses the light motif of Laius
theme as a non verbal plea from Leia to
her son to stand down moving on later
when vice-admiral whole doe takes over
command from Leia Williams uses another
light motif as she and Poe but heads ma
Mystere post it's almost a bit more
subtle but as she spoke underneath you
could barely hear a horn playing a
tweaked version of kylo ren's theme
Williams is very slyly linking holder
with kylo to suggest Poe doesn't trust
her in this moment his eyes her secrecy
an alternative leadership style is as
much a threat of the resistance as kylo
Ren is so if like me the first time you
saw this movie you were annoyed and a
little suspicious of hold those
intentions this subtle musical cue might
have been part of it now earlier I
mentioned the composer Richard Wagner
his work has actually been cited
directly by John Williams as a major
influence on his original score for Star
Wars Williams said he wanted to use this
vogner style romantic bombastic
orchestral swell to give a sense of
classic adventure to a story set in
space calling its cross cultural
mythology this idea of cross cultural
mythology comes up again when kylo and
grey were struggling for control of
Luke's lightsaber listen to the music
that plays at the precise moment the
saber handle splits into two halves
which of course coincides with the
supremacy splitting into halves
this melody is possibly vogner's
Siegfried light motif from the Valkyrie
in the Ring cycle now this might sound
familiar and the past observers have
pointed out but this also could have
inspired Williams's force theme and yeah
I definitely hear the similarity there
[Music]
but I think in this moment the light
motif serves a similar purpose in the
Valkyrie Siegfried has to forge a
shattered sword that's his task
similarly this whole Star Wars saga is
also a mythology about a sword and the
people who wield it and in the same way
Williams sampled Wagner to introduce us
to the sword in 1977 he's now using the
same light motif to dramatize its
shattering when this possible connection
was pointed out to last Jedi director
Rian Johnson he responded critically
with this emoji showing a heart a bolt
of lightning and a sword so it looks to
me that this parallel with Luke's
lightsaber and Siegfried's broken sword
was intentional now one of the sweeter
examples of john williams's scoring came
during Luke and Leia's reunion williams
combined three light motifs first the
force theme as Luke reveals himself to
Leia
[Music]
then as the brother and sister talk the
music immediately segues into Luke and
Leia's music from the original trilogy
[Music]
it's you and finally at the end of their
reunion Luke hands her Hans lucky dice
from the Falcon and the music shifts to
Han and Leia's love theme from the
original trilogy
[Music]
raid your terms all right moving on to
the final super interesting light
fatigue from John Williams right after
this scene as luke walks outside to
confront kylo williams sets an f minor
chord with the orchestra playing a four
note pattern F C a flat and then F again
this four note melody is from Richard
Strauss's opera Elektra where the lead
soprano sings about the ghost of her
father Agamemnon Williams might be
sampling this light motif about a
ghostly paternal presence as a clue
about Luke here as a ghostly force
projection haunting kylo Ren at least
this connection was noticed by the
actual opera singer who sang that song
and one final bonus audio detail I
noticed during this sequence we listen
closely you can hear the Wilhelm scream
Wilhelm scream is a stock sound effect
of a guy's high-pitched yell used in a
ton of action movies including pretty
much every Star Wars film and property
it's kind of a tradition for sound
editors now the windscreen was a little
hard to find in the last Jedi but it
comes up very discretely here when kylo
in anger slashes his blade through
Luke's force projected body alright
maybe Luke could just feel that burn
back on a hunch - a question for you
guys which John Williams Star Wars theme
is most memorable for you personally I
think duel of the fates from the Phantom
Menace is the best thing about that
movie they might be my favorite music
from the whole franchise but I'm
throwing it over to you let me know your
thoughts down below or tweet me directly
I da boss and follow new rock stars on
Twitter at new rock stars for updates on
our videos and be sure to watch my other
videos on the last Jedi our full movie
breakdown and the follow up with even
more details you might have missed like
this video and subscribe to new rock
stars for these kinds of deep dives and
all the stuff you love including pretty
much everything Star Wars related but
also analyses of the music and all these
movies and TV shows that you like and if
you really want to help us grow and
cover even more properties you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially Lori
Denham thanks for watching guys bye